أريد زيلينسكي حيا !
هكذا أمر بوتين قواته،
فموسكو تعلم مكان الرئيس الأوكراني
ولكن زعيمها لا يريد قتله،
وأمر أن يؤتى به أمامه في روسيا،،،
يتسابق الجنود الروس لتنفيذ أمر بوتين
فمن يفوز بتلك المكانة ويقبض على عدوه؟...
خيانة أمريكية غريبة لكييف
وللرئيس الأوكراني،
وإخلافهم لوعود بسيطة فماذا تنتظر أوكرانيا
منهم يا ترى؟..
زيلينسكي يرد ويخاطب العالم
(احمونا نحن نموت ببطئ)
ما الذي جرى لك يا هذا؟
وأين هم حلفاؤك ليحموك اليوم؟،
لماذا تستجدي من لم يعرك اهتماما؟
ألم يجدر بك أن تجلس على الطاولة
لتفاوض عدوك، عوضا عن استعطاف
الغرب الذين تركوك في فوهة المدفع؟
هذا ما جنته يدك يا زيلينسكي! ...
.الوساطات لا تتوقف وأردوغان
آخر الواصلين، وساعة الحسم
اقتربت وعقارب ساعة الدب الروسي
قاب قوسين أو أدنى من التمام،،
فماذا بعد سقوط العاصمة الأوكرانية؟
لقاء جمع بوتين  مع نفتالي بينيت
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي،
لمناقشة تطورات الأزمة،
ومحاولة تل أبيب حلحلة تعقيدات هذه الأزمة
والجلوس مع طرفيها على طاولة المفاوضات..
بينما قالت موسكو لتل أبيب،
أنهم يعرفون مكان رئيس أوكرانيا زيلينسكي
ولكن هنالك أوامر من بوتين
بأن يقبضوا عليه حيا،
بوتين : لاتحدثونا عن القانون الدولي
الذي نعرفه!!
فإذا قبضنا على الرئيس الأوكراني
بالزي العسكري سنعامله معاملة الأسرى
ولن نقتله كما فعلتم بالقذافي وصدام حسين ..
قوات روسيا تستعد لاقتحام العاصمة
الأوكرانية كييف،
فماذا تبقى بعد العاصمة؟
ولماذا ترك الغرب وأمريكا أوكرانيا
وحيدة في مواجهة الدب الروسي؟!!،،،
وهل كانت روسيا تعلم أن الغرب
مجرد فقاعة ولن يجرؤوا على مواجهة موسكو؟
في مشهد صار معتادا في العاصمة،
صافرات الإنذار تدوي في كييف
وسط توقعات بهجوم روسي واسع،،
القوات الروسية تكثف عملياتها بشكل
غير مسبوق في كييف،
ورصد لتحرك كثيف لكتيبة دبابات روسية
في محيط العاصمة..
فهل يعني ذلك رغبة موسكو حسم الحرب
سريعا بإسقاط العاصمة؟ وهل يعني سقوط العاصمة
انتهاء الحرب؟
بعد موافقة روسية على فتح ممرات إنسانية آمنة
في المدن الأوكرانية.. آلاف الأوكرانيين
يهربون من مدنهم بما في ذلك العاصمة كييف،
والمسؤولون الأوكران يحذرون من الاستعدادات
الروسية في محيط كييف لاقتحامها،،،
بينما خرج الرئيس الأوكراني فولوديمير زيلينسكي،
وناشد قادة دول العالم، حماية الأوكرانيين،
وتزويدهم بالمعدات للدفاع عن أنفسهم،
يقول زيلينسكي
( إن لم تدعمونا على الأقل بالطائرات
وهو واجبكم، فأنتم تريدون موتنا ببطيء،
وهذه مسؤولية السياسيين في العالم،
وقادة الدول الغربية من الآن وإلى الأبد،
(السيطرة الجوية)
الجو يحدث الفارق،
فمن يسيطر عليه يربح الحرب..
إلحاح زيلينسكي على الغرب بدعمه
بطائرات حربية ومقاتلة..
وعلى الرغم من امتلاكه لطائرات بيرقدار التركية
والمجربة في عمليات مشابهة،
لكن زيلينسكي يريد طائرات مقاتلة،
لمعرفته بأهمية السيطرة على الجو،،
وهنا أكد وزير الخارجية الأمريكي
سعي بلاده الحثيث لتمكين أوكرانيا
من امتلاك طائرات حربية..
يحاول الغرب ضرب روسيا بدعم كييف
بطائرات من الإرث السوفييتي،،
لكن الغرب وأمريكا يخافون ردة فعل الدب الروسي،،
فقد حذر رجل الكرملين القوي فلاديمير بوتين
أن أي حظر للطيران أو دعم بطائرات مقاتلة
قد يجعل الدولة الداعمة في مواجهة موسكو
ومن ذا الذي يريد الوقوف أمام روسيا يا سادة...
- وزير الخارجية الأمريكي قال إن أمريكا
أعطت الضوء الأخضر لبولندا  لتتبرع
بـ 28 مقاتلة لأوكرانيا
- فصرحت روسيا أنها ستضرب أي دولة
تقوم بتزويد أوكرانيا بالطائرات أو المقاتلين..
- فخرجت بولندا في نفس اللحظة
تعلن أنها لن ترسل مقاتلات
ولن تسمح لأوكرانيا باستخدام مطاراتها .
روسيا تدافع عن امنها القومي بكل شراسة
(معركة المطارات الاستراتيجية)
سهلت القوات الروسية مهمتها في أوكرانيا
بالسيطرة على المطارات أو تدميرها..
فقد سيطرت قوات موسكو على مطار أنتونوف
في غوستوميل الذي يبعد ٨كيلومترات
عن الطريق المؤدي إلى العاصمة كييف،،
بينما أطلقت موسكو صواريخها على بقية المطارات
سواء أكانت حربية أو مدنية لتمنع أوكرانيا
من الإقلاع منها وتمنع كذلك وصول الدعم
إلى كييف عبر تلك المطارات......
(طعنات في ظهر أوكرانيا)
وزير خارجية أمريكا بلينكن..
طائراتنا لن تحلق ضد الطائرات الروسية،
ولن نخوض مواجهة مباشرة ضد روسيا...
وتقارير تفيد أن البيت الأبيض يؤخر المعلومات
الاستخباراتية عن كييف، وسط توجيه أمريكي
سري لفرض قيود على تبادل المعلومات
مع أوكرانيا خشية مواجهة مباشرة مع روسيا...
محكمة العدل الدولية تبدأ النظر في طلب أوكرانيا
اتخاذ إجراءات عاجلة، تدفع روسيا لوقف الحرب،
وفي افتتاح الجلسة الأولى لهذه القضية،
شهدت الجلسة غياب ممثل عن روسيا..
وفي الجلسة نفت أوكرانيا أمام المحكمة اتهامها
بارتكاب إبادات جماعية في إقليم دونباس..
وأكد ممثل أوكرانيا أن بلاده تواجه حربا عدوانية
(كما وصفها) مطالبا بوقف الحرب فورا...
القوات الروسية تسيطر على ٦ مدن رئيسية
في مقاطعة زابوريجيا، ،
كما قالت وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية
أن القوات الروسية سيطرت على مدينة إيربن
شمال غربي كييف،
وأن القوات الروسية أصبحت على بعد
٢٠كم من العاصمة كييف أيضا..
مشاهد لمقاتلي الشيشان يتقدمون شمال أوكرانيا..
وتقارير تشير لتجنيد روسيا لجنود سوريين
للقتال إلى جانب قواتها في أوكرانيا..
الرئيس التركي أردوغان يجري اتصالا هاتفيا
مع نظيره الروسي بوتين، ويدعو إلى
وقف شامل لإطلاق النار من أجل فتح ممرات آمنة
لعبور المدنيين وأكد أردوغان استعداد بلاده
للمساهمة في أي طريقة لحل سلمي أو ديبلوماسي..
فيما قال له بوتين: إن العمليات العسكرية
تجري وفقا لما هو مخطط لها ووفق الجدول الزمني
المحدد،، في الوقت الذي أجرى الرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون اتصالاً دام قرابة ساعتين مع بوتين
أيضا وأبدى الرئيس الفرنسي قلقه البالغ
بشأن التهديدات النووية، جراء العمليات
التي تمت بالقرب من المفاعلات النووية...
وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية تصدر بيان  تقول فيه،
أن روسيا تدفع ب95% من قواتها المشاركة
منذ بداية الأزمة إلى أرض المعركة،
وأضافت أن روسيا قد أطلقت ٦٠٠صاروخ
على مختلف المناطق في أوكرانيا..
بينما أكد البيان أن روسيا لم تستطع السيطرة
على الأجواء الأوكرانية..
وتضيف الوزارة الأوكرانية:
أن الجيش الأوكراني يشن هجوما معاكسا
في خاركيف، ويستعيد السيطرة على إحدى
البلدات المهمة. وأضاف الجيش أنه حال دون سيطرة
قوات روسيا على خطوط السكك الحديدية
على نهر دنيبرو.. وأن القوات الروسية
تتحرك باتجاه العاصمة كييف بعد السيطرة الكاملة
على إيربن..
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تقول أنها دمرت تقريبا
كل سلاح الجو الأوكراني.. ودعت الوزارة الدول
المجاورة لأوكرانيا بعدم استخدام مطاراتها
لمساعدة كييف في العمليات العسكرية
لأن ذلك يعني انخراطها في الحرب.
وستكون في مواجهة روسيا بذلك...
فهل تجرؤ تلك الدول على مواجهة موسكو علنا؟
الرئيس الأوكراني، يعلن تدمير مطار فينيتسا
بالكامل بعد استهداف المدينة بصواريخ روسية،
ليجدد بذلك مطالبته بإنشاء منطقة حظر جوي
فوق أوكرانيا، فهل لا يزال لديه وقت
ليطالب بذلك؟ خصوصا وأن القوات الروسية
على أبواب عاصمته كييف؟
(أسوأ السيناريوهات في حال سقطت كييف بيد القوات الروسية)،،،
في خاركيف لم يكن أمام قوات كييف إلا الانسحاب
داخل المدينة، وبعد أن سيطرت عليها القوات الروسية،
تم استدراجهم إلى حرب الشوارع والعصابات،
وهذا هو السيناريو المتوقع إذا قررت القوات الروسية
دخول كييف، وهو آخر رهان للقوات الأوكرانية،،،
بإجراء قتال داخل الشوارع،
وهذا النوع من المعارك يصعب حسمه
ويطيل أمد الحرب فالمواطنون ليس لديهم
ما يخسرونه بعكس الجيش النظامي الذي يقاتلهم،،،
وهناك قد يتم اعتقال الرئيس أو حكومته،
لذلك فالغرب يطرح خيارات بتهريب القادة
إلى بولندا، وقد نصحوا بمكوث القادة كلٌ في منطقة بعيدة
عن الآخر حتى لا يتم اغتيالهم أو أسرهم،
وبذلك فإن أبرز المرشحين لخلافة زيلينسكي
حال اعتقاله أو قتله هو رئيس البرلمان،..
ويبدو أن الغرب يعدون العدة لحكومة منفى
قد تمكث في أوكرانيا لإدارة الحرب لاحقا، ،
لن يكون غريبا أن تسيطر روسيا على أوكرانيا
بالكامل وليس العاصمة كييف فقط،
ولكن الغريب هو الموقف الغربي!!،
الذي دفع بأوكرانيا لحرب ليست قادرة حتى على الدفاع
عن نفسها فيها، لكن بعد هذا كله
ما الذي استفاده الغرب، غير أنه كسب عداء الدب
الروسي؟، ألا يستحي الغربيون من أقوالهم
التي تناقض أفعالهم؟، وماذا بعد السيطرة
على أوكرانيا أيها الدب الروسي؟..
...